[Music]
when I was in the sixth grade my friends
and I at such a pivotal moment in our
lives realized how bored we were there
was a lack of excitement in our
adventures we had found that we had done
everything we could possibly think of to
fill in an empty space of time we'd have
sleepovers play video games watch movies
walk around the neighborhood and even
after all of this we were still bored
and the worst part about this was that
we knew that other kids felt the same
thing too so after talking and
discussing amongst ourselves we realized
that as much as we tried to fix our
boredom we weren't doing anything
substantial about it that's why we
decided that we wanted to make people
laugh we wanted to make funny videos
that joked about things that no one
really joked about we wanted to joke
about our quirky quiet town of Alton
Texas now I'd love to tell you that I'm
here to share that my videos have
millions of views and that I've sold
tons of merchandise worldwide but
unfortunately like many of the ideas
that we have we never made our videos
our idea a reality I know right now
there's probably at least one of you
who's like man this guy's depressing is
he gonna keep talking like this but
there's a reason as time went on more
and more of us left the group until
eventually all of us left the group all
of us except for one my friend couldn't
let go of his idea so after we all left
in the sixth grade he decided to make a
team
members would come in and leave out
fluctuate he learned how to use complex
computer software and he learned how to
work with cameras he would make videos
on drama comedy things here and there
and I didn't know any of this because I
hadn't seen or talked to him in six
years my friend the one who never gave
up on his idea has now launched his own
videography company like him and the
rest of the world
we all have tons of ideas every day and
there was something different about him
because six years ago my group of
friends and I we all had the same idea
but he was the only one who actually saw
it through how many of you ever feel
Drive inside of you that tells you take
a chance
what if why not for many of us while
we're sitting down at work eating lunch
are waiting to drift off to sleep we get
a sense of that feeling that drive that
we had and then after a few minutes of
reminiscing we continue doing what we're
doing for some of us that feeling comes
around often it makes us remember how we
always wanted to start our own band take
a road trip with our friends or even
something small like clean up the trash
in our local park and it sucks because
the thing that you remember the most out
of everything is the fact that you
didn't do it my friends and I we were in
the process of making these videos we
had so many opportunities to get
something done I can remember how many
times an adult came up to us and told us
hey I actually might know some things a
kid would come and tell us I know how to
edit videos or even amongst ourselves we
would tell each other you can come here
to my house and we'll work on it
all opportunities that we never actually
took as time went on I realized that I
had to stop giving up my ideas
years and years went by and we never had
we never met up I never had the
opportunity to explore that idea I had
many ideas each day but they would all
pass by until eventually I came upon an
idea that I couldn't afford to let go of
an idea that I couldn't afford to regret
that idea was the South Texas ideas
festival scx I I come from a place where
typically youth are not encouraged to do
better
they are discouraged they feel that they
can't do the things that many other
people can do and this was a problem
because we didn't want this to happen
anymore we don't want people to feel
like they needed to leave our home to do
something better our festival was
student-led with a team of high school
students we put on a festival that
hosted 300 students from across our
region and it was great we received tons
of commendations for it and I know it
sounds like an overnight success story
but it really wasn't and one of the main
questions that people would ask us was
where did you get the drive to do this
when I was a little kid I learned a lot
from what was going on around me I came
from a home where the only way to make a
living was to pick up plastic bottles
and cans and sell them to processing
plants my first real job was helping a
woman set up her booth at a flea market
from 7:00 in the morning to 3:00 in the
afternoon for $20 my neighbor's son
learned how to cut hair when he was
eight years old because it was the only
way he and his family could afford a
haircut at such a momentous time in my
life I thought that I was limited that
my community was limited my
neighbourhood was limited all because of
our circumstances and then
came my crazy grandpa I went home and
one day he was watching TV and he told
me Michael look I want this not the
horse the pole it's a horse patient's
pole it basically teaches a horse to be
patient and he told me I want this and I
asked him how are you going to afford it
we don't have the money and he said I'll
find a way so I forgot about it I was
walking around the house and during that
time he left and he got a wheelchair
from I have no idea where and a giant
metal pole from I have no idea where and
when I got back home I went into the
backyard and this is what I saw my crazy
grandpa had cut the wheelchair in half
attached it to the top of the pole stood
it upright and tied the horse to it and
in just three days we not only taught
the horse at a standstill we taught it
how to run in circles and I remember
when I saw this I was my mind was blown
away because I had never seen someone
take that initiative to do something
despite the odds and thinking about it
now now that I'm older I realize that
I'm not that impressed in the actual
pole because at the end of the day it's
just a pole I was more impressed in the
fact that my grandpa went out and did it
he didn't let resources get in the way
of his idea he didn't find a reason not
to do it he didn't choose to experience
regret if you feel that idea that tug
then I'm telling you do what my grandpa
did because that same drive that he had
is what made the South Texas ideas
festival possible it was a team of high
school students we had no idea what we
were doing we just we just knew that we
wanted
present a big festival to the people of
our community to show them everything we
got if you feel like an idea is worth
something be it yours or someone else's
if you feel that an ideas worth time
constraints rejections and failures then
let me give you a piece of advice stop
what you're doing put down your phone
pause the TV show that you're watching
hold off on that nap for five more
minutes and think you're bored right
well now is the perfect opportunity for
you to take that road trip the perfect
opportunity for you to start that band
the perfect opportunity to clean up some
trash now the next time that you're
bored I beg of you I implore you to get
excited because you might just be on to
your next best idea thank you
[Applause]